database is where the individual
database breaks is not a fixed number it
depends on how the database is being
used the main problem with relational
databases is that you're effectively
limited to two one server and you have
the option of course to scale up that
server larger and larger in a vertical
capacity but at a certain point you have
to do sort of creative destruction in
order to take it further you can shard
the database which virtually every large
company does but there's a whole bunch
of trade-offs involved in doing that and
a lot of maintenance a lot of systems
work involved the promise of new sequel
is that a lot of this stuff can be
automated and much easier to maintain
and available to a much broader class of
companies which in turn opens up a whole
new world of what's possible in their
applications things they might not have
thought about before
so there are many different types of
databases so beyond the classic
relational database about 10 or 15 years
ago the big talk was in object databases
and then with the re-emergence of no
sequel databases this notion is then
transformed a bit and so we generally
hear about four types of databases
columns stores things like Cassandra or
HBase we hear about document databases
like MongoDB we hear about key value
stores like couchbase or aerospike we
hear about graph databases my zeal for J
or Tyson
the cap theorem essentially states that
in a database you have to choose between
consistency availability and partition
tolerance and that you may choose two of
the three but you can't have all three
together what does this mean in practice
for no sequel databases it means you
have to choose between consistency and
availability means you have to choose
between consistency and availability
because any cluster has partitions in it
now this question is actually more
complicated than than that because
availability in terms of the cap theorem
is a more of an academic construct when
what you care about fundamentally is
whether your application can reach the
cluster and what it can do also all of
these databases live can live in
multiple places on that consistency
availability spectrum so I tend to say
there's a good place to start but it's
not the only way to evaluate where you
want to be and that's why I like to
prefer the term sort of speed versus
reliability because I think that makes
more sense from an application and
business perspective than the kaffir
I believe that column family databases
document databases key value stores are
all converging around a kind of
distributed key values storage platform
with more and more features being
layered on top I think what we're going
to see really exciting and interesting
progress is along where they take this
underlying facilities and the different
kinds of features they layer on top for
for example right now using each of
these databases requires a certain
amount of domain expertise you really
have to design your application to be
aware of the underlying platform you're
using I see different vendors doing
things like layering SQL support on top
of their key value platform that's an
incredibly powerful idea now there's no
such thing as a free lunch in a
distributed system so in doing so
there's going to be things that those
are better at and things that those are
worse at but I think you're going to see
a lot of interesting progress in terms
of in terms of how consistency is
achieved in terms of how people are able
to get acid transaction semantics on top
of it and how people are able to make
the development process easier in these
databases now I would like to separate
even though the column family document
and key value store databases are
converging in many ways this is just a
subset of no sequel databases this is a
subset I like to think of as operational
data these tend to be the applications
that need to handle a high amount of
load which generally means a large
number of transactions but relatively
simple transactions there's another
whole piece of that whole big data space
and that's doing this analytic workload
things where you know where Hadoop
traditionally comes in and being able to
run queries across these massive
databases is an area that's just
beginning to emerge and I think there's
going to be a lot of very interesting
progress there as people do refinements
to MapReduce various flavors of
real-time MapReduce and so forth we see
MongoDB used a lot for real-time and a
because it's very very simple to get
data in and very simple to query across
a cluster through that we've also used
Cassandra for real-time analytics with
Cassandra you have to be you have to
spend perhaps more care upfront modeling
your data in the way you want to bring
it out but it's extremely powerful
platform for getting data in and out
quickly